justice un million d'euros 1 million
d'euros pour avoir passé 15 ans en
prison pour rien c'est l'indemnisation
comptes obtenues patrick dils et sa
famille information du républicain
lorrain
patrick dils rappelons le avait été
acquitté du meurtre de deux enfants
après toutes ces années de détention
c'est le montant le plus important
jamais accordé christophe medard
jean-pierre pasteur les rideaux sont
tirés la porte reste close la famille
dils n'a pas souhaité réagir aux
informations révélées par la presse
locale les habitants de
montigny-lès-metz ne s'en prive pas et
ils sont unanimes
très honnêtement je pense qu'elle
méritait plus je pense que ça n'est
vraiment pas grand chose pourquoi petite
goutte d'eau qui torroglosa parce que
c'est à lui et à sa moitié de sa vie
quoi en fait
condamné à perpétuité pour le meurtre de
deux enfants à montigny lès metz puis
acquitté en avril 2002 patrick dils doit
percevoir 700 mille euros de dommages et
intérêts une somme qu'il estime
justifiée au vu des 15 années passées en
prison
j'aurais préféré ne pas toucher un
centime et ne pas avoir vécu toutes ces
galères ce que j'ai vécu ne se chiffre
pas son avocat lui est plutôt satisfait
et naturellement supérieure à la
première offre qui avait été faite par
l'agent judiciaire
le montant final est le plus important
jamais attribué en france dans une
affaire d'indemnisation de détention
provisoire abusive l'état devraient
aussi verser 200 mille euros à la
famille de patrick dils cent mille euros
étant allouée au titre des frais de
justice
l' enquête sur le double meurtre de
montigny-lès-metz elle n'a toujours pas
abouti